Cliff would you ever work for Xbox and
create a small team similar to the team
that made Hi-Fi Rush
I mean I'm open to anything at this
point the thing is you know this is
another one of those other phrases that
I learned is don't sit at a table that
you can't walk away from right and so
that's the thing about me being I'm
financially independent you know and I I
have full creative control over the
multiple IPS that I'm working on right
and if somebody wants to come and you
know fund it and do some stuff I'm I'm
all ears honestly my brother so man
trebelius journey I mean man this we
could go on with you for hours bro this
this is amazing you know a true honor
one thing I respect about you it's just
your brutal honesty with a little bit of
the self-deprecate you but you always
come full circle and I love the passion
that you put in your projects you know
the personal say